securities and exchange commission chair
gary gensler has called cryptocurrency
the wild west regulators have cracked
down for years on individual token
issuers but so far the sec has not taken
any major enforcement actions against
the big crypto exchanges the commission
has made waves in one area though crypto
lending
we've seen the sec and six state
attorneys general threaten lawsuits and
shutdowns for companies offering lending
so this begs the question what is crypto
lending and why is it the one part of
the crypto universe where we've seen
regulators publicly threaten action
against the big names here's how what
happens with crypto lending could affect
the entire crypto market
let's start with the basics crypto
lending is exactly what it sounds like
investors who hold cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin or ethereum and even many stable
coins like usdc can lend their holdings
of coins to other investors through
lending platforms investors can do a few
things to start they can use crypto as
collateral for their own loans they can
also lend their crypto to other traders
who might want to use it to lever up
their positions to make bigger bets or
speculators might look to borrow crypto
to take out short positions betting the
prices will fall it's actually pretty
similar to old-fashioned banking with
crypto platforms like celsius blockfi
and others playing the role of bankers
users lend the platform their crypto and
the platform lends it to other users or
traders or platforms in exchange for a
fee
then the platform passes some of that
profit back to users in the form of
interest
since crypto is a new asset class and
one that lacks a lot of actual cash
traders and exchanges who want to borrow
in the space are willing to pay a high
price in order to do so but why would
anyone want to lend their crypto
the answer quite simply is it pays
very well
lending can be an attractive proposition
for crypto hodlers excuse me crypto
holders with diamond hands who don't
want to sell before prices go to the
moon but also want to earn some stable
passive income and the yields are pretty
nice one platform is offering up to 14
interest on some stable coins and up to
8.5 interest on bitcoin compare that to
the
0.06 percent interest the average u.s
bank savings account pays and you can
see why there's a lot of interest
nobody wants to have cash sitting in a
bank account earning zero percent that's
jeff doorman chief investment officer of
arca investments his firm manages 700
million dollars in digital assets and
he's both a lender and a borrower in the
crypto space well the same thing is now
true in digital assets if you own it and
you're not doing anything with it
there's a variety of different ways to
now earn a yield by staking it by
participating in an ecosystem or by
lending it to somebody else who's going
to do those things instead of you and
you can earn a return for lending it to
them and as long as you think you can
make enough in your trading volume to
offset the amount of interest that
you're paying you're willing to do so
but
and there's always a but
crypto lending isn't just a matter of
watching your gains stack up there are
some real risks
first unlike a traditional savings
account your deposits are not insured by
the federal deposit insurance
corporation or anyone else that means if
your crypto goes missing or if it gets
stolen in a hack
or if the company just doesn't want to
give it back to you well that's too bad
and we've already seen it happen in
august hackers stole 600 million dollars
worth of crypto from finance platform
poly network and at thodex the crypto
exchange's founder and ceo allegedly
fled with about 2 billion worth of funds
those are just a couple examples the
second potential problem is that much
the crypto market is backed by other
cryptocurrencies and stable coins rather
than cash
that can mean reduced liquidity you
could find yourself waiting a lot longer
to get your crypto back
and there's the potential for users
coins to get stuck during times of
market distress or extreme volatility
this is especially important in a market
like crypto where 20 daily price swings
come with the territory stable coins are
meant to be stable but they aren't
always and in fact no one's quite sure
what the backing assets are behind some
of the biggest stable coins this has
made regulators worry that in a pinch
crypto users could see their money
disappear so you can see there are some
potential dangers with lending and
borrowing crypto but why is it that
regulators have stepped in on lending
but held back on restrictions for crypto
trading at big exchanges to explain that
i spoke with my colleague alexander
osipovic who covers exchanges and market
structure for the journal
many of the firms that are doing uh
cryptocurrency lending and borrowing
right now they have the viewpoint that
they don't need to register with sec
they're not doing anything that touches
on u.s securities laws obviously the
regulators disagree with that i guess
the main concern from the regulator's
standpoint is that there's really little
disclosure about what's actually
happening behind the scenes with these
companies the regulators basically don't
want crypto to grow into a giant asset
class in its own right without any sort
of regulatory framework around it they
want to impose disclosure requirements
on different crypto firms they want the
police for fraud and they want to make
sure that they have a handle on this
asset class before it gets so big that
it might become a source of systemic
financial risk the sec reportedly sent a
notice to coinbase in september warning
that they were planning to take action
against the company for its crypto
lending product coinbase says the sec
pointed to the howie test a 1946 rubric
that seeks to determine whether or not
something is a security you may not have
heard of it but the howie test is really
important in the world of financial
regulation it asks three questions
one
is there an investment of money two
is there a common enterprise meaning
will customers assets be mixed in with
other customers assets to fund the same
venture or project and three is there a
reasonable expectation of profit from
the efforts of others
legal experts seem to agree that all
three apply to crypto lending this is
important because if crypto lending
qualifies as a security then the sec has
the right to regulate it or even shut it
down the commission has not yet
announced any major actions related to
buying and selling crypto against big
exchanges like coinbase binance and ftx
which ran ads during the world series as
the official crypto exchange of major
league baseball without the sec stepping
in with enforcement actions most crypto
exchanges have largely just assumed they
have the green light to do as they
please in fact despite the actions taken
by the sec and the six states most
crypto lenders are still operating as
well while coinbase shut down its
planned crypto lending option blockfi
celsius and others are still in business
they're awaiting rulings on orders
brought against them by the various
attorneys general so what does all this
mean for crypto investors and for the
crypto market as a whole crypto lending
is different than crypto trading because
most crypto holders aren't earning
interest on their coins however
decisions by the states on crypto
lending could be seen as setting a
precedent for the broader industry if
regulators are going to take a position
on lending they could also be close to
taking a position on crypto trading and
that could mean regulations are coming
for dogecoin litecoin stellar polka dot
chain link hell the whole market
so don't sleep
if you enjoyed this video make sure and
hit the like button and if you're
interested in markets and want to watch
and learn more subscribe to this channel
so you can keep up with my latest as the
late great nipsy hustle once said it's
six degrees in life opportunity
preparation they meet it's nice
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]